PROFESSOR: So we come to the
part that a lot of students
have been asking
about, but which
in fact is entirely optional.
So that if you care to skip
this little piece of video,
you're welcome to.
It's not going to appear
on any exam or anything.
But people have
consistently asked
how they choose
which method of proof
to use among ordinary
induction or strong induction
or well-ordering.
And the answer is that it's
hard to tell them apart,
because in an easy
technical sense,
they're really all equivalent.
So let's look at
them one by one.
First of all, it's clear
that ordinary induction
is a special case
of strong induction.
In the ordinary
induction, you're
allowed to assume only p of n.
In strong, you can assign
everything from p of 0
up to p of n to
prove p of n plus 1.
But you don't have to use
all the extra assumptions.
You could just use p of n so
that any ordinary induction
can be seen as just a special
case of a strong induction.
It would be a little misleading
to call it strong induction,
but it is strong induction.
So why bother with it?
Well, the answers, basically,
it's an expository difference.
It helps your reader to know
that the proof for n plus 1
is only going to depend on n not
on the k's that are less than n
as they would typically in a
genuine strong induction proof.
Second, is some argument that an
ordinary induction going from n
to n plus 1 is more intuitive
than strong induction that
goes from anywhere less than
or equal to n up to n plus 1.
I'm not sure that I
subscribe to that,
but I've heard people
make that claim.
All right.
There's another
perspective, which
is interesting and maybe
surprising, which is,
why not always use
ordinary induction?
Oh, wait a minute.
How do you replace
strong induction
with ordinary induction?
Well it's easy.
Suppose that you've
proved for all m P of m
using strong induction with
induction hypothesis P of m,
what have you done?
Well, it's the same
base case whether you're
using ordinary or strong.
But in strong, you would
do an inductive step
where you actually assumed not
just p of n, but P of for all k
less than or equal to n.
And then using all those
hypotheses about P of k,
you prove P of n plus 1
in the strong induction.
Well, how do you turn it
into an ordinary induction?
Just let Q of n be that
assumption, that for all k
less than or equal to n P of k.
And if you think
about it for a moment,
just revising the
induction hypothesis
to include that universal
quantifier, for all k less than
or equal to n, means that the
strong induction on P of k
becomes an ordinary
induction on Q of n.
And we have a trivial
change decorating
a bunch of occurrences
of formulas
with for all we have
converted and strong induction
into an ordinary induction.
So we see that strong
induction and no power
above and beyond
ordinary induction.
It just lets you omit a bunch
of universal quantifiers
that would otherwise have to be
made explicit if you were going
to do it by ordinary induction.
Then why use strong?
Just precisely,
because it's cleaner.
You don't have to write
those for all k less than
or equal to ends all over.
And now we come to the
final question about,
what's the relation between
the well-ordering principle
in induction?
Well, it's basically
the same deal.
You can easily rephrase
an induction proof.
An induction proof,
just transform it's
template to fit the template of
a well-ordering proof and vice
versa.
We're not going into the
details of exactly how,
because it's not important,
but it is routine.
It follows that well-ordering
principle is not
adding any new power
or even new perspective
on the mathematics
of any given proof.
It's just a different
way to organize and tell
the same story.
And it also means
conceptually, which
is nice that these apparently
different inference rules,
strong induction,
ordinary induction,
well-ordering principle,
there's really only one.
And the others can be
justified in terms of it
and explained as
variations of it.
So that's intellectually
economical
to not have a proliferation
of different reasoning
principles, which brings us
to the question of which one
to use.
And all I can say is that
it's a matter of taste.
The truth is that when
I'm writing up proofs,
I will often try
different versions.
I'll try it by
ordinary induction.
And I'll try it
by well-ordering.
And I'll read the two and
decide which one seems
to come out the more cleanly.
And I'll go with that one.
So there isn't any simple
rule about which to choose.
But in a certain sense,
it really doesn't matter.
Just pick one.
The only exceptions
to that, of course,
is when on an exam
or similar setting,
you're told to use one of
these particular methods
as a way to demonstrate that you
understand it, then, of course,
you can't pick and choose.
So finally, we come to a
pedagogical question about,
why is it that in 6042 we taught
well-ordering and principal
first, in fact,
the second lecture,
and are only now at
the end of third week
getting to the induction
principle, which is much more
familiar, and people
argue they like it
better, at least most of them.
Well, the answer is it's
a pedagogical strategy.
And it's one, in fact, which
the authors disagree with, not
united on.
My view is that we're better off
doing well-ordering principles
first.
And the reason is that our
impression from conversations
with students, and surveys,
and from exam performance
shows that only about
20% of the students
get induction no matter how hard
we try to explain and teach it.
They report worrying
about things
about that assuming P of
n to prove p of n plus 1
is somehow circular.
And it's certainly measurable
that 20% or so of the class
just can't reliably do
proofs by induction.
Now this baffles the
80% to whom it's obvious
and who know how
to do it easily.
And it baffles us instructors.
We can't figure out what the
problem is that those 20% have.
And we've been trying
to teach induction
lots of different ways.
On the other hand,
nobody has trouble
believing the well-ordering
principle and working with it.
And they certainly don't
have any harder time using it
then they do using ordinary
induction or strong induction.
And this conceptual
problem about is it safe
and do I really believe
in it just doesn't come up
with a well-ordering principle.
Everybody agrees
that it's obvious
that a non-negative
set of a non-empty set
of non-negative integers is
going to have at least one.
And so we chose to do
well-ordering right away,
because there's no
overhead in explaining it.
And it lets us get going
on interesting proofs
from the get go as
opposed to waiting a while
or spending a couple of lectures
working through induction
and get leaving that with
the main if only method
that people have
for proving things
about non-negative integers.